the Kings have one unusual move where  two pieces can move at the same time  that is castling in this position the  White King can move to the Kings side  where the White King slides over two  squares to g1 and the white rook slides  over two squares to the f1 square white  castles black can also Castle why can  Castle queenside he can move his King  two squares to the c1 square followed by  his rook you cannot Castle by moving  your King through check if we see after  castling the white rook on d1 controls  the d8 square therefore black's  opportunity of castling queenside would  be illegal in this position black has  the choice of either castling option  because the d8 square is not controlled  and therefore castling queenside for  black is legal  you cannot castle when your king is in  check and you cannot castle where your  King moves through a square controlled  by your opponent  you